are we alone in the universe people have
asked that question for centuries and
more recently pop culture has produced
some pretty imaginative renditions of
alien life now scientists know a lot
more about where and how to look for
life elsewhere and how it might be
different from life here on earth so we
asked some scientists a slightly
different question if there are
extraterrestrials out there what do they
look like
the response is ranged from the obvious
to the extravagant planetary geologist
Cathy Thomas capita had a very specific
vision of life in a harsh environment
like Mars here's what she wrote to us in
my humble opinion a martian organism
would need to meet several structural
criteria simple construction a tough
outer membrane for protection from the
elements a cellular envelope with
multiple layers one or more flagella to
travel from hostile to more suitable
environments and some sort of system
that uses Mars's magnetic hotspots to
navigate those environments but life on
another planet might not always be
obvious I would suggest that's the most
likely form of life anywhere in the
universe is unicellular organisms
underground that's planetary scientist
Linda Elkins tanta we're on any planet
is the temperature most likely to be
relatively constant where water is most
likely to be available in liquid form
where where habitability has the the
longest time that it that is likely to
be constant and and I think that it's
under the surface planetary scientist
Dorian Abbott's first guest was
microbial but then he painted a pretty
fantastical picture of a planet not
unlike mercury where a central star's
light reaches every part of the planet
once a month giant fuzzy caterpillars as
big as moose with huge elephant noses
move around on the ground and they eat
off all the yummy green plants that
creep across the Terminator from the
light side of the planet
and they suck up all the goodies with
their noses but out of the darkness wolf
bears with saber teeth and giant eyes
pounce spread them up and eat them
meteorologist Bob Hazen bets on
something smaller in scale here's how he
responded to our question my first pass
would be a clump of microscopic spheres
or rods so microbes living on the
chemically active surface of an iron or
sulfur bearing mineral astrophysicist
Heather Knudsen looks for bio signatures
in the atmospheres of distant exoplanets
here's what she wrote
when I picture alien life I usually
picture something like a bacterium
unicellular life that's really what
we're looking for
astrophysicist Kristin Manute turned to
an unlikely source for thoughts on
aliens his three-year-old son what do
you think alien life might look like
tweet your drawing to hashtag dry UT and
check out a special issue of science
news on the search for extraterrestrial
life